une barquette de la zone une pizza
surgelée à inchy parmentier qu'est ce
qu'on va manger ce soir un plat préparé
vite fait prêt en une minute au
micro-ondes banal aujourd'hui voire
critiquer la cuisine industrielle était
pourtant révolutionnaire dans les années
60 les l'idéal que l'union pour un
départ en week-end pour les navigations
de dernière heure et pour les films
d'acteurs qui on a fait de la france
deux jambes la cuisine industrielle
c'était moderne un moyen de libérer la
femme des fourneaux est ce que vous
savez faire les mêmes temps que votre
mère pas tellement sur la cuisine et les
journalistes de l'époque étaient formels
c'était les mêmes préparation qu'à la
maison
une pilule comme dans les cuisines et la
préparation de la langue de boeuf en
piquant préparer comme chef loi et sauve
à la paix où curieusement les proches de
langues une bonne langue de boeuf en
barquette ça vous tombe pas et ce n'est
que le début des plats préparés fin des
années 60 c'est l'invention du micro
ondes un four qui permettra de
réchauffer ses bons petits mijoter 1 du
ce
en quelques minutes les ondes radar au
service de la cuisine est un gag ou une
réalité
jugez en vous même ce plat surgelé
sortie de las cases spéciales de votre
réfrigérateur sera prêt en 30 secondes
grâce à ce four à micro ondes
alors que le consommateur est
aujourd'hui informé sur la nocivité de
ces places industrielle dans les années
70 les journalistes ne s'alarme pas des
additifs et autres agents de texture
chimiques mais regrette le bon vieux
temps où la femme restée au foyer
les nouvelles conditions de vie ont
changé la vie familiale de mère en fille
les traditions se perdent 63 % des
françaises ne font plus la même cuisine
que leur mère bien que le goût du plat
mijoté bien mitonné reste français les
femmes sont elles encore préparé cette
bonne cuisine qui rendait heureux leur
avis très dès la porte franchie
malgré ces remarques la société active
est avide de cette cuisine industrielle
prêtes à l'emploi
la preuve avec l'augmentation de
production dans cette usine de plats
italiens
lusine à demeurer en 66 elle a démarré
sur une production moyenne de 15 mille
tonnes à l'heure actuelle sur la base
1980 nous sommes environ à 64 mais on ne
voit plus qu'une des plus par quatre la
production initiale aujourd'hui la part
des dépenses en plats préparés et estimé
à près de 4% du budget alimentaire des
français
une alimentation décrié sources
d'obésité de diabète et de maladies
cardiovasculaires
[Musique]